I mean once think about guns I'd ra I'd
owe them to look at them uhhuh just cuz
I like the way they look especially if
like just to have the dirty hairy gun no
I do like like a old uh a revolver I
like a revolver I just think it's
[__] bad I think that you should only
get six attempts to shoot someone only
Six Bullets yeah I feel like those
semi-automatic and fully automatic those
are for [__] those are like everybody
gets a trophy like everybody gets a kill
like if you can't squeeze off six and
hit whatever you're mad at that I mean
you lose it's like a carnival game
carnival game you get three trials
you're getting twice as many tries with
a [__] revolver you ever seen those
big banana those extended [__]
magazines psych why don't you learn how
to shoot better it also doesn't look
good aesthetically it's like a crooked
dick yeah hanging off you know what's an
elephant dick you ever see the elephants
just walking by you ever see those
videos with the big swinging [__] you
know Bill I I don't I don't tend to look
that kind of stuff up it's not animal
porn it's not the other animal on her
back I wasn't saying you were watching
that